55 % de notre chiffre d'affaires à
l'état et à la commune qui sont donc
très intéressé au fait que le
fonctionnement soit clean on fait
exactement comme les banques les
compagnies d'assurance parce qu il ya
d'argent suspects nous sommes dans
l'obligation de le déclarer comment se
répartit 100 euros de mise globalement
aux machines à sou par exemple moi j'ai
dans l'obligation de vendre en moyenne
85% que nous on n'a absolument aucun
intérêt à ce que quelqu'un aille
raconter qu'il s'est ruinée au casino
passé repas pouvait dépenser des sommes
extrêmement importantes allant jusqu'aux
millions d'euros aujourd'hui ça n'existe
et on est beaucoup plus dans le loisir
aujourd'hui ce qui fait notre marge
c'est la fréquentation et le nom
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce mardi 7 septembre
l'identité dévoiler des hommes forts à
la tête de l'afghanistan trois semaines
après la prise de pouvoir par les
talibans mohammad hassan hakmoun devient
chef de l'exécutif son numéro deux et le
mollah baradar cofondateur des talibans
alors qui sont ces hommes que peut-on
attendre de ce nouveau gouvernement qui
se dessine est déjà ce soir le chef des
talibans demandent au nouveau
gouvernement de défendre la charia régis
le sommier grand reporter spécialiste de
la région nous donnera son analyse
en france des tirs de mortiers de
cocktails molotov face à des balles de
défense de la police la cité des
tarterêts à corbeil-essonnes a depuis
cinq jours des airs de zones de guerre
l'interpellation le 2 septembre d'une
mère de famille diffusée sur les réseaux
sociaux aurait mis le feu aux poudres
alors quelle marge de manoeuvre pour les
autorités dans ces quartiers dits
sensibles est il réaliste de parler de
zones de non droit ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face
la justice et le droit comme dernières
armes pour tenter d'expliquer
l'inexplicable
c'est un procès historique est
titanesque qui débute demain à paris
celui des attaques du 13 novembre 2015
ou 130 personnes avaient perdu la vie 20
accusés 330 avocat et quelques 1800
partie civile c'est la plus grande
audience criminelle jamais organisé en
france mais qui est aussi redoutés par
de nombreux survivants et par les
familles des victimes
trois semaines après avoir pris le
pouvoir en afghanistan les taliban n'ont
dévoilé aujourd'hui une partie de leur
futur gouvernement qui sera dirigé par à
mohammad hassan à coude les précisions
de mourad gazier f envoyée spéciale à
kaboul pour alerter internationale
tout d'abord c'est un gouvernement
provisoire c'est ce que les taliban ont
déclaré eux mêmes la composition du
gouvernement à venir n'est pas clair il
reste à savoir s'il sera élu
pour le moment les talibans ont choisi
le modèle iranien avec un guide
spirituel aiba tous là à ronda il n'est
pas élu ait agi hors d'un cadre
gouvernemental
en tant que leader suprême reconnu des
talibans
il a nommé personnellement mohammad
hassan a round premier ministre de ce
gouvernement
auparavant il a été ministre des
affaires étrangères des talibans quand
ils étaient au pouvoir en 2000 2001
il est perçu comme un fonctionnaire un
personnage certes religieux mais plus
modérée
mais il ya aussi d'autres nominations
par exemple mohammad et jakub au poste
de ministre de la défense
il est considéré comme un personnage
incarnant la ligne dure son père étant
un chef de guerre qui a combattu contre
l'armée soviétique pendant la guerre
d'afghanistan
il ya aussi sirajuddin haqqani qui est
également le fils d'un chef de guerre
actuellement il est recherché par les
états unis qui offrent une récompense de
l'ordre de cinq millions de dollars pour
sa tête en raison de sa responsabilité
dans des bombardements en 2008 au cours
desquels un citoyen américain a été tué
tous ces personnages au sein du nouveau
gouvernement ont fait partie de
l'insurrection la rébellion des talibans
contre l'occupation américaine pendant
cette guerre
il ya donc très peu de compromis les
gens s'attendaient à ce que les taliban
puisse peut-être même inclure des
membres de l'opposition voire même des
femmes
ce n'est pas le cas d'après ce qu'on a
vu jusqu'à présent il semble qu'après la
chute du panjshir aps entièrement
réalité mais les talibans ont pris la
majeure partie de la vallée du panchir
est décimé les rebelles et les forces
anti-talibans peut-être se sont-ils
sentis ans hardy par leur progression
par la rapidité avec laquelle ils ont
vaincu la résistance mais comme je l'aï
déjà dis aime pas tout à fait il se bat
encore dans les montagnes
peut-être les talibans ont ils décidé qu
étant donné la facilité et la rapidité
avec laquelle ils ont pris le contrôle
du pays et la vitesse à laquelle ils ont
vaincu l'opposition il ne devrait
peut-être pas faire de compromis avec la
communauté internationale
avant de retrouver régis le sommier sur
ce plateau pour évoquer analyser ce
gouvernement s'arrête quelques instants
sur les principaux défis auxquels ce
régime peut être confronté
isolé par le passé les dirigeants
talibans vont devoir faire face à une
grande défiance sur la scène
internationale
si le groupe a des contacts avec
plusieurs puissances régionales ni le
pakistan l'iran la russie la chine ou
encore le qatar n'ont pour l'heure
reconnu le nouveau pouvoir en place à
kaboul
dans l'un des pays les plus pauvres du
monde les nouveaux dirigeants pour
lourde tâche la refondation de
l'économie une économie qui était jusque
là sous perfusion car alimenté par
l'aide internationale jusqu'à 40% durant
deux décennies de guerre
selon un porte parole du groupe
islamiste la chine s'est engagée à
maintenir ouvertes son ambassade en
afghanistan et à accroître son aide au
pays notamment pour lutter contre le coc
vide
mais les nations unies craignent cet
hiver une catastrophe humanitaire et un
effondrement total de ses services de
base
parmi les dizaines de milliers d'afghans
ayant fui le pays
de nombreux postes qualifiés ont été
évacués ces dernières semaines et
viennent désormais à manquer pour
reconstruire l'afghanistan
juriste fonctionnaires technicien
après l'attentât du 26 août aux abords
de l'aéroport de kaboul revendiqué par
la branche locale de l'état islamique
les nouvelles autorités vont aussi
devoir protéger la population d'une
autre faction divergentes l'état
islamique au corps hassan qui a d'ores
et déjà manifesté son rejet du pouvoir
taliban
alors qu'attendre de ce nouveau
gouvernement qui sont ces nouveaux
maîtres de l'afghanistan pour en parler
nous sommes avec régis le sommier grand
reporter arte france bonsoir
régis merci d'être avec nous lisons
milan ac cet aliment on imagine que
c'était un peu le casse-tête au final
une équipe assez éclectique alors ils
ont mille temps il ya eu plusieurs
événements en évoquer le panchir
effectivement le principe sion de
prandières probablement retarder
l'annoncé de cette nomination de deux
des principaux ministres n'y a pas tout
le gouvernement encore ce qu on peut
noter c'est que on dira c'est
l'éclectisme la talibane c'est à dire
que ça compte contient du modéré et du
dur ce gouvernement donc il ya donc le
mollah ah koon qui a été nommé donc par
le guide suprême un à-coup nada le
pedigree du mollah akoun on sait c'était
quelqu'un qui était dans l'ancienne
équipe le mollah koons ada le guide
suprême aussi était dans l'ancienne
équipe où il chapeautait la sphère
judiciaire s'est cassé entre 96 et 2001
les talibans ont fait preuve d'une
dureté absolue édictant des lois
quasiment à l'absurde et des dates des
interdits en permanence donc là c'est le
voilà c'est le descendant de cette
équipe là qui dirige aujourd'hui le
mollah à coup ne fait pas fait partie
aussi de ses anciens talibans et le
mollah baradar qu'on présente souvent
comme un éclairé entre guillemets
quelqu'un qui a pu négocier avec les
américains pendant huit ans et qui
présente une phase de modération doit
son nom qui veut dire frères c'est le
mollah omar qui l'a appelée baradar
qu'il appelait frère donc la filiation
est les voilà dans l'équipe il ya
comment sirajuddin haqqani qui est une
figure emblématique de l'el durée
militer combattante c'est-à-dire 2000
elle militaire pardon des talibans et
est donc là on a essayé de satisfaire un
petit peu poussé
qualifié de
certains des membres du gouvernement ont
été arrêtés à certains moments soit par
les services pakistanais soit par les
américains certains sont les héritiers
d'ailleurs de de deux figures qui ont
été drones et par là même par les états
unis donc voilà on peut remarquer
d'abord contrairement à ce qui avait été
annoncé cette possibilité qu'il y ait
une femme ou une possibilité qu'il y ait
à une figure de l'opposition à dallas
dallas par exemple ou même certains
disaient peut-être le fils du commandant
massoud tout ça est tellement la vie
assez illusoire et pour le moment c'est
de montrer un front uni entre des
talibans qui n'ont pas forcément été
unis toujours et des gens qui finalement
cédé trouver un ennemi commun avec la
mairie qui n'ont plus cet ennemi commun
donc là il faut tenir le pouvoir il faut
montrer qu'intérieurement ils sont
capables de le faire et ensuite après il
y aura peut-être des gages pour la seule
la communauté internationale un sens on
sait que hier anthony blinken a appuyé
cette idée d'inclusivité cherrad un jean
yves le drian de la nouvelle équipe pour
le moment elle ne s'est pas manifesté on
sait aussi que c'est ce que les
américains souhaité lors de l' commence
quand même vous le rappeler hier il ya
eu des négociations avec les talibans et
ses promesses faites aux américains qui
pour l'instant ne sont pas tenues oui
tout à fait alors les promesses elles
ont été faites depuis février 2020 il
était question dans l'accord de paix que
les américains avaient conclu avec le
mouvement taliban qu' il y ait des
négociations avec le gouvernement afghan
cessé ses négociations à l'époque n'ont
jamais rien donné le gouvernement afghan
est tombé là ce qu'essaie de faire les
américains c'est peut-être de faire une
sorte de marchandage à nouveau un deal
avec les talibans en leur disant montrer
un visage plus ouvert chassez les
extrémistes engagez vous justement à
clarifier vos liens avec al qaïda il
faut rappeler que tous ces gens n'ont
jamais formellement comme ont remis en
question ce qu'on appelle la bahia c'est
à dire l'acte d'allégeance que oussama
ben laden avait fait au mollah omar qui
a été renouvelé dans toute l'histoire du
mouvement taliban donc comment le
successeur de ben laden aussi ayman al
zawahiri l'avait fait donc le cette
allégeance aux talibans existe toujours
de la part d'al qaïda donc tout ça c'est
quand même des choses assez trouble les
talibans n'ont pas commenté ce qui
donneront une suite à ces actes une
suite cette filiation et ça c'est très
important pour la communauté
internationale en particulier pour les
américains mais pas seulement également
les chinois les russes vous rappeliez
dans le reportage que aucun des pays
pour le mandat vers oro n'avait reconnu
le gouvernement taliban ça se produira
les talibans ont fait d'ailleurs appel à
l'allemagne disons qu'il souhaitait
entretenir des relations évidemment pour
des questions financières on imagine
bien parce que encore une fois ce qui
est très important pour eux c'est
pouvoir tenir le pays asseoir leur
souveraineté sur l'ensemble du pays ce
qui est très difficile en afghanistan et
puis gérer l'économie et les finances
dans un pays qui est un des plus pauvres
de la planète et qui a énormément
énormément de carence encore aujourd'hui
le chef des talibans ce soir à a pris la
parole il demande au nouveau
gouvernement de défendre la charia c'est
l'une des premières déclarations ça dit
quoi justement ce sont 6 de défense de
la charia alors la charia vous savez
quand on va voir les talibans j'ai
toujours quelque chose c'est toujours
quelque chose qui mettent ils vous
disent par exemple vous leur dit allez
vous recommencez à interdire comment le
sport aux femmes les cigarettes la
musique etc et ils vous répondent en
disant tout ce que la charia autorise
jeu l'autoriserait tous cas l'un cardy
jeu l'interdirait c'est toujours très
facile un espèce de paravent permanent
chez les talibans de dire nous
appliquerons la charia maintenant
qu'est-ce que ça signifie concrètement
est ce que ça signifie mettre en cause
le droit des femmes visiblement ce qu'on
aura encore une remarque c'est que il y
à des manifestations de femmes qui
demandent leur droit à kaboul et dans la
plupart des villes du pays on avait même
eu jusqu al jalal abad sont comme des
zones très très conservatrice pour le
moment certaines de ces manifestations a
été contrarié les talibans ont tiré en
l'air à kaboul pour disperser une mais
il n'y a pas eu comment dire de scène
comme on avait pu les voir lors de leur
arrivée au pouvoir en 96 c'est à dire
des lynchages des pendaisons des
exécutions dans les stades ça on l'a pas
vu il ya eu des règlements de comptes
mais des règlements de comptes
discrètement contre les ennemis
traditionnels les talibans c'est à dire
des forces armées formé par les
américains qui étaient véritablement les
ennemis des talibans pendant 20 ans donc
ça il ya eu ce genre d'exactions pour le
moment sur les manifestations des femmes
on les a vues elles ont pu se dérouler
là apparemment ils les ont interdites
faisant dit qu'il ne souhaitait pas
qu'elle se reproduise on va voir dans
les jours prochains comment il va se
comporter surtout si ces femmes qui ont
bien l'intention de continuer à
redescendre dans les rues et à acclamer
leurs droits continuent à le faire avec
certainement le soutien aussi d'une
bonne partie de la communauté
internationale et des pays occidentaux
on imagine régis vous restez avec nous
si vous le voulez bien puisque huit
jours après la fin du retrait des
soldats américains les réfugiés 1 tente
de refaire surface et s'organiser une
vie loin de leurs racines parmi eux
certains ont trouvé refuge en france
justement vous avez pu vous entretenir
avec l'un d'eux s'appelle naciri les
journalistes il a réussi à quitter
kaboul et c'est un entretien exclusif
pour rtl france
nasir khan nasir tout d'abord bienvenue
à paris la dernière fois que nous nous
sommes vus c'était à kaboul il ya un
mois environ pouvez vous me dire
pourquoi vous avez décidé de quitter
l'afghanistan
le monde pensait que kaboul risquer
d'être prise après quelques mois tout le
monde pensait qu'on aurait quelques mois
avant de devoir partir
mais la situation a évolué très vite
personne ne s'attendait à une
détérioration aussi rapide c'est
pourquoi il y avait autant de gens qui
souhaitaient fuir lorsque les talibans
sont arrivés
qu'est ce qui vous faisait penser que
votre profession et vous-même seriez
particulièrement en danger avec les
talibans au pouvoir
au cours des deux trois dernières années
avec mes collègues nous avons travaillé
en tant que journaliste pour la liberté
d'expression afin de dévoiler les
atrocités dont les taliban et le
gouvernement étaient accusés
nous menions des enquêtes poussées à la
recherche de la vérité qui souvent
étaient dissimulés
c'est pourquoi l'arrivée au pouvoir des
talibans nous a mis en grand danger
les talibans sont très nombreux dans la
province de wardak là d'où je viens j'ai
personnellement révélé des atrocités
commises par les talibans dans la
province et dans tout le pays j'avais
déjà reçu des avertissements on m'avait
déjà dit de ne plus m'intéresser à ces
sujets
j'avais également très peur pour ma
famille qui était en danger à cause de
moi
comme c'est moi qui faisait peser sur
eux une menace je me sentais responsable
et de leur sécurité
comment avez vous fait pour obtenir
l'aide des français pourquoi avez vous
décidé de vous tourner vers l'ambassade
de france qui vous a aidé à quitter le
pays
j'ai contacté de nombreux journalistes
français avec lesquels j'avais collaboré
au cours des trois dernières
ils ont organisé une rencontre avec
l'ambassade de france
mes amis français ont ensuite confirmé à
l'ambassade que j'avais travaillé pour
les médias français pour la liberté
d'expression pour révéler la vérité
ils ont une forme de responsabilité
envers les journalistes qui ont
travaillé avec les médias français donc
ils ont contacté l'ambassade et après
quelques consultations l'ambassade m'a
accordé un visa schengen carlos
racontez-nous le jour de votre départ
comment est ce arrivé
c'était un dimanche matin je suis allée
à l'aéroport de kaboul tout allait bien
quittant la maison quand soudainement
tout le monde s'est mis à crier que les
talibans étaient entrés dans la ville
qu'ils étaient proches qu'ils allaient
prendre le pouvoir
je me suis dit que l'aéroport serait
l'endroit le plus sûr pour moi je suis
arrivé là-bas vers 9 heures du matin il
y avait beaucoup de trafic j'ai fait 5
km à pied
j'attendais pour embarquer vers 18
heures quand les gens ont commencé à
crier que les talibans arrivait alors
les employés se sont enfuis le pilote
aussi s'est enfui tout ce qu'ils
pouvaient en fuite les autres ont passé
la nuit à l'aéroport
la nuit même j'ai contacté mes collègues
français qu'ils m'ont dit de me réfugier
à l'ambassade de france il leur avait
parlé et ils m'autoriserai à entrer j'ai
quitté l'aéroport à trois heures j'ai
croisé des points de contrôle taliban à
ce moment là je portais des vêtements
afghans et des sacs ils m'ont demandé
d'où je venais je leur ai dit que je
venais de l'aéroport et ils m'ont dit de
passer
puis j'ai atteint l'ambassade ils m'ont
laissé entrer nous avons attendu je
crois trois jours dans l'ambassade de
france et après ces trois jours lorsque
la situation à l'aéroport s'était un peu
calmée que la foule s'était dispersé
l'ambassade a évacué le bâtiment a mené
les ressortissants français également
les journalistes en danger à l'aéroport
où nous avons finalement été exfiltré de
kaboul jusqu'à part je crois qu'il
devait y avoir entre 5 et 600 personnes
à bord 500 personnes à bord oui à bord
youtube est en forte baisse
vous m'avez également dit avoir vu cet
homme suspecté d'avoir des liens avec
les talibans qui surveillaient le poste
de contrôle pour les talibans qui a aidé
les gens à passer rentrer dans
l'aéroport et même embarqué dans un
avion français il était mis sous
surveillance en france que pensez vous
de lui pensez vous qu'il est venu en
france pour commettre des actes
terroristes où qu'ils cherchaient
véritablement s'échapper
c'est une histoire terrible si les chefs
talibans eux mêmes ne veulent pas se
battre ne veulent pas rester en
afghanistan
imaginez si les talibans eux mêmes ne
veulent pas rester en afghanistan ne
veulent pas se battre qui voudra rester
les talibans sont au pouvoir il a quitté
le pays parce qu'il savait que la
situation n'allait pas s'améliorer c'est
pour ça qu'il est parti pensez-y
si même les talibans veulent partir
alors les civils veulent absolument s'en
aller rejoindre une chance merci
le sommier vous aviez travaillé avec ce
journaliste des journées comme nacira ce
qu'il en reste encore beaucoup en
afghanistan n'ont pas pu s'échapper il
en reste oui il y en a qui sont encore
menacées il ya aussi un certain nombre
de personnages que nous avons rencontrés
là-bas qu'on a essayé d'aider et qui
malheureusement n'ont pas pu partir
notamment des femmes ce qu'il faut
savoir que c'est quand une femme veut
partir en afghanistan elle peut pas
partir tout seul une famille est
toujours dans la structure de la société
afghane la femme est toujours sous la
tutelle d'un homme et elle ne peut pas
partir tout seul en particulier une de
nos hommes nos personnages du
documentaire que nous avons fait pour
canal+ qui s'appelle camargue houle qui
est elle a vraiment pris les armes
contre les talibans est menacée a réussi
aujourd'hui à se planquer est dans
kaboul elle est véritablement en danger
donc il ya un certain nombre de
personnes comme ça qui sont menacées qui
restent sur place qui malheureusement
n'ont pas pu passer les évacuations sont
terminés on parle d'une zone on parle
d'un certain nombre d'américains aussi
qu'ils chercheraient encore à partir
j'ai pas entendu de détails pratiques
sur le fait que des gens puissent à
nouveau quitter l'afghanistan des
talibans ont dit que les afghans
pourrait quitter qui pourraient demander
des visas qui pourrait partir à
l'étranger tout s'arrête encore bien
hypothétique
et ça demande à être vérifié sur place
contre les taliban ont promis ont assuré
anthony blinken un qui était sur place
au qatar hier qu'il ne bloquerait pas
les civils afghans qui souhaite quitter
l'afghanistan a sur ce point faire
confiance aux talibans ils ont dit tout
et le contraire et en même temps ils ont
dit qu'ils ne souhaitaient pas que les
avenants quitte le quittent
l'afghanistan ça c'était dans l'idée de
ne pas créer de flots de réfugiés au ses
flots de réfugiés existe même en
frontière du pakistan et a déconné des
files d'attentes incroyable avec des
situations d'humanitaire assez
dramatique des turcs également sont en
train de recevoir beaucoup de réfugiés
donc c'est difficile pour eux de
contenir le ces gens là c'est ce qu'ils
avaient dit au départ maintenant où ils
ont des langages qui peuvent changer en
fonction des interlocuteurs tout ça
voilà et dans la dans leur opération de
séduction de la communauté
internationale ils veulent montrer
qu'ils sont prêts qu'ils sont pleines de
bonnes dispositions et grands tout cas
tous les travers qu'on avait pu voir
dans leur précédente administration ne
sont plus les mêmes qu'ils ont changé
que le visage des talibans et du
mouvement taliban a changé et puis après
ils vont vous dire comme vous l'avez
signalé qu' il souhaitait une
application de la charia voilà mais la
charia qu'est ce qu'il ya derrière c'est
ça la vraie question dernière question
être un journaliste indépendant comme
leona fier que vous avez interviewé
aujourd'hui
en afghanistan y aurait il en reste
malheureusement ça sera très difficile
parce qu'un certain nombre de médias
indépendants qui existaient qui avait pu
se développer sous l'occupation
américain je pense par exemple à une
télévision à jalalabad qui s'appelait
nickas cette télévision était porté par
une une figure féminine mal à l'âme et
one qui comme on était vraiment une star
dans une zone encore une faute on est à
l'est de l'afghanistan et des zones très
traditionnel pachtoune est mal à l'âme
et one a été assassiné et depuis dans sa
télévision qui j'ai visité les locaux
c'était dans un bunker en sous-sol
menacé d'attentats etc et plus aucune
femme ne travailler dans cette chaîne de
télévision que deux quais devenue cette
chaîne de télévision aujourd'hui je peux
pas vous le dire j'en sais rien il ya un
certain nombre de médias indépendants
comme ça qu'ils avaient réussi à émerger
voilà les talibans viennent de conquérir
le pouvoir il ya trois semaines
quel type de relation et vont-ils avoir
avec ces médias là est-ce qu'ils vont
être autorisés est ce que des voix
dissidentes vont être autorisés à
s'exprimer pendant leur pouvoir ça c'est
tout une question est évidemment ils se
savent quand même observer scruté par la
communauté internationale et de la
communauté internationale et c'est là où
il ya peut-être quelque chose à jouer
dépend une aide financière une aide
économique le fait que le pays ne sombre
pas et c'est pas dans l'intérêt des
talibans que le pays sombre parce que
les afghans sont capables de se révolter
aussi contre eux il ya aussi beaucoup de
figures qui attendent de voir ce que ce
que ce mouvement taliban va donner et il
ya des risques énormes de guerre civile
ces chefs d'état-major de l'armée
américaine qui le déclarait il ya deux
jours il y à des risques de guerre
civile dans l'art en afghanistan il ya
beaucoup d'armes qui circulent on a vu
beaucoup laissé par les américains mais
y en a plein d'autres et les gens sont
armés et les gens attendent un petit peu
or certains sont dit ben finalement
laissons les talibans laissons-les on
verra ce que ça donnera ils nous ont
promis qu'ils souhaitaient l'unité
l'inclusivité etc ils ont fait
d'ailleurs déjà des démarches en par
exemple en tolérant la langue ouzbek
avec le pachto haidari comme langue
officielle de l'afghanistan les ouzbeks
sont une minorité
les tadjiks les hasards à on va voir
quelle va être leur comportement par
rapport à ces minorités pour le moment
il n'y a pas eu
d'affirmation d'un ordre dictatorial qui
viendrait mettre en cause ces gens et
ces communautés voilà c'était encore tôt
régis le sommier ans d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir et suite à l'annoncé de ce
nouveau gouvernement formé par les
talibans les regards se tournent
évidemment vers la diplomatie américaine
comment va-t-elle réagir à la
composition de cette nouvelle équipe
nous retrouvons notre correspondant à
new york à thomas bonnet bonsoir thomas
ce que les autorités américaines ont
réagi publiquement à cette annonce
non aucune réaction officielle pour le
moment de la part des autorités
américaines on a simplement eu un
commentaire de la part de james à qui la
porte parole de la maison blanche qui a
été interrogé par des reporters
justement sur ce nouveau gouvernement
formé en afghanistan elle a ainsi
expliqué que rien ne presse pour le
reconnaître et que cela dépendra à des
étapes que prennent les talibans mais ce
qu'on peut dire évidemment c'est que la
formation de ce nouveau gouvernement en
afghanistan n'est pas à réellement
conforme aux demandes formulées ces
derniers jours par la diplomatie
américaine un gouvernement composé de
talibans et dans ce gouvernement il ya
même des personnes qui sont recherchés
par les autorités américaines c'est le
cas par exemple du ministre de
l'intérieur sirajuddin haqqani pour
lucky le fbi offre jusqu'à 5 millions de
dollars pour toute information menant à
son arrestation alors on attend
maintenant une éventuelle déclaration de
la part d' anthony blinken le chef de la
diplomatie américaine qui vous savez et
en déplacement au qatar depuis hier et
d'ailleurs avant l'annoncé de ce nouveau
gouvernement il avait lui annoncé des
avancées justement dans les négociations
avec les talibans notamment sur la
question de l'évacuation des civils à
d'afghanistan je propose d'écouter
anthony blinken
nous sommes également adressé aux
talibans à ce sujet y compris ses
dernières heures ils ont dit qu'il
laisserait les personnes avec des
documents de voyage par tient librement
où les attendront sur cette question
tout comme des dizaines d'autres pays la
communauté internationale tout entière
attend que les talibans respecte cet
engagement le chef de la diplomatie
américaine a d'ailleurs cité un exemple
celui d'une famille de quatre américains
qui ont réussi à quitter l'afghanistan
par voie terrestre il s'agit de la
première évacuation depuis le 31 août
dernier mais la question maintenant c
est ce que cette évacuation est
réellement due aux efforts de la
diplomatie américaine il y à un débat
parce qu'en fait à cette opération
d'évacuation a été menée par une équipe
de vétérans américains financés par des
dons privés et le meneur de cette équipe
a déclaré
à fox news que le département d'état
américain surévalué en quelque sorte son
implication dans cette évacuation pour
dit il tirait les lauriers et spi sauver
la face d'une administration qu'il
estime complètement dépassés par la
situation en afghanistan est thomas le
rôle de ces autorités d'autant plus en
question que certains estiment même
qu'ils bloquent des départs
oui les témoignages font état du fait
que si des avions sont toujours cloués
au sol dans l'aéroport au nord de
l'afghanistan l'aéroport mazar i sharif
c'est par manque d'autorisations données
par les autorités américaines plus que
par un quelconque blocage des talibans
c'est notamment ce qu'affirme michael
youn c'est un ancien des forces
spéciales américaines qui est devenu
journaliste et qui participe lui aussi à
des opérations d'évacuation privé
écoutez son témoignage
il nous avions trois avions au sol
c'était des jets privés ils ont été
payés par l'équipe d'un de mes amis son
nom éric l'est son équipe avait payé
trois avions il avait des avions civils
au sol qui les attendait et l'armée
américaine ne laissait même pas passé
les civils américains avec des
passeports américains notre plus gros
problème pour faire sortir les gens est
en fait le gouvernement américain pas
les talibans je sais ça semble fou mais
le plus gros problème ce n'est pas les
talibans les talibans nous ont en fait
aidé dans certains cas
alors le département d'état américain
explique qu'il n'a pas assez de
personnel sur place pour procéder à tous
les contrôles nécessaires pour permettre
à ses avions de décoller une situation
de blocage qui exaspère en tout cas un
certain nombre d'acteurs de terrain
entre elles six ans et 1300 personnes
seraient concernées sans qu'on ne sache
réellement avec précision le nombre
d'américains qui sont toujours en
afghanistan en attente d'être évacués en
tout cas malgré le déplacement de tony
blinken au qatar en ce moment une partie
de l'opposition ici aux etats-unis
particulièrement les républicains vous
pouvez l'imaginer et bien ils expriment
leurs critiques contre l'administration
de joe biden accusés de ne pas faire
tout son possible pour procéder à cette
évacuation des civils encore en
afghanistan merci thomas bonnet en
direct de new york
et c'est dans ce contexte que la russie
à positionnelle ses troupes au
kirghizstan proche des pays voisins de
l'afghanistan notre envoyé spécial sur
place antoine claireaux nous en dit plus
ça y est c'est parti pour trois jours de
manoeuvres militaires ici dans l'est du
kirghizstan les exercices ont
officiellement débuté tôt ce matin et
déjà tout au long de la matinée des
colonnes de blindés avec des tanks mais
aussi des pièces d'artillerie des avions
ou encore des hélicoptères ont visé des
cibles qui se trouve sur les flancs des
montagnes juste derrière moi alors
l'objectif de ces manoeuvres organisées
au sein de l'organisation du traité de
sécurité collective et bien c'est je
cite la préparation et la conduite
d'opérations visant à neutraliser des
formations illégal armes et d'écouté oui
on a priori justement que la situation
militaire et politique dans la zone de
responsabilité de l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective reste
difficile
du groupe
elle est malheureusement moins favorable
dans la région d'asie centrale et se
développe sur fond de prise du pouvoir
par les talibans en afghanistan
pays frontalier du tadjikistan le
terrorisme international et l'extrémisme
religieux et restent élevés
[Musique]
nous lançons aujourd'hui des manoeuvres
conjointes avec les unités des forces
collectives de déploiement rapide
hrubesch 2021
pendant ces manoeuvres nous allons
travailler de manière pratique sur
l'application des forces et des moyens
du système de sécurité collective dans
le but de protéger les états membres de
l'organisation
sont clairement visés ici les groupes
islamistes en provenance de
l'afghanistan tout proche qui pourrait
bien débordé sur les pays d'asie
centrale et pays d'asie centrale allié
de moscou est le nom donné à ces
exercices est d'ailleurs assez
significatif assez explicite il s'agit
des exercices hrubesch 2021 hrubesch qui
veut dire en français limite frontières
en france à présent direction corbeil
essonnes dans la cité des tarterets plus
précisément où des affrontements ont
lieu entre les jeunes de quartiers des
policiers durant cinq nuits consécutives
en cause une interpellation à la suite
d'un rodéo urbain ce jeudi qui a dérapé
et la diffusion d'une vidéo sur les
réseaux sociaux on en parle maintenant
avec guillemin rossi sur place bonsoir
guillemin vous êtes donc à corbeil
essonnes racontez-nous que s'est il
passé
précisément
et bien stéphanie bien stéphanie tout
est parti d'une vidéo vous l'avez dit
sur laquelle on voit une interpellation
d'un jeune homme environ 18 ans par
plusieurs policiers en bas de son
immeuble l'arrestation est musclé on
entend également les cris de la mère qui
est descendu et qui ne supportent pas le
spectacle elle tente de s'approcher de
son fils mais là l'un des policiers l'a
gaza l'aide d'une bombe lacrymogène
cesse ce geste qui a mis le feu aux
poudres car dans ce quartier des
tarterêts comme ailleurs du reste s'il
ya bien un public auquel il ne faut pas
toucher et bien ce sont bien les mères
de famille et résultat depuis cinq nuits
dans ce quartier des jeunes s'affrontent
avec les forces de l'ordre ce quartier
des tarterêts dont j'ai pu rencontrer
l'un des habitants il s'appelle omar
soumaré il est acteur il a grandi ici je
vous propose de l'écouter
il est plus qu'important d'aujourd'hui
parler de de ce qui s'est passé ces
derniers jours dans mon quartier ça
c'est obligé un objet de prendre la
parole sur des choses qui ne changent
pas qui ce conflit qui ce truc non au
musée de prendre la parole et c'est le
fait que je prends la parole aujourd'hui
peut peut changer quelque chose par la
suite entre les forces de l'ordre et les
habitants de ce quartier je serais
sûrement l'un des plus heureux qu'est ce
que vous leur dites aux forces de
l'ordre aujourd'hui je vais leur dis
tout simplement un moment donné des
d'essayer de se familiariser avec
avec les avec les habitants de des lieux
où il travaille parce qu'à un moment
donné ont cohabité ensemble et il ya
certains comportements qu'il faut éviter
d'avoir même si je comprends bien que
l'on comprend alors
leur job est assez difficile je me mets
à leur place à un moment donné mais a
aussi un moment donné de se mettre à la
place des gens qui habitent à et
dc déjà dans un premier temps d'arrêter
de faire du mal physiquement aux jeunes
et aux familles habitant ici et que ce
soit morale ou physique en fait dans les
deux cas qu'ils arrêtent de faire du mal
en fait alors ce lundi une médiation a
été tenté par la municipalité une
rencontre entre un collectif de maires
du quartier et des représentants des
forces de l'ordre nous ne voulons pas de
georges flotte d'adama traoré ici à
corbeil a dit l'une des femmes la
commissaire divisionnaire quand elle a
tenté de justifier l'acte de son agent
ce qui n'est pas du tout passé parmi les
habitants un autre commissaire également
présent à lui présenter des excuses mais
cela n'aura visiblement pas suffi
puisque des échauffourées ont éclaté peu
après la réunion alors aujourd'hui dans
ce quartier des tarterêts où nous sommes
nous sommes allés bien l'ambiance était
calme mais on sent que la colère n'est
toujours pas retombée mais on verra donc
pour cette nouvelle nuit où l'on craint
évidemment des violences merci beaucoup
aux guillemins rossi avec olivier
molinari merci à vous et on le disait un
la crainte évidemment d'une nouvelle
nuit de violences urbaines dans le
quartier des tarterêts où se trouvait
lieux marc aussi à marseille un dealer
interpellé par la police a été lui
libérer de force par une dizaine
d'individus incident qui arrive moins
d'une semaine après la visite des
manuels mettront dans la cité phocéenne
alors question est ce que l'état
toujours de l'autorité dans ces
quartiers sensibles c'est l'objet de
notre décryptage ce soir
[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler et dc
délégué du syndicat unité sgp police fo
bonsoir et dc2 merci d'être avec nous à
vos côtés madjid messaoudene militants
anti raciste ancien élu de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir madjid
messaoudene merci d'être là une dizaine
d'individus âgés le dire qu'ils se sont
jetés sur des policiers à marseille 1
pour faire libérer un dealer franchement
interpellé des policiers qui tient la
sonnette d'alarmé avant de vous faire
réagir je voudrais justement vous faire
écouter la réaction de l'un d'entre eux
mathieu vallée le secrétaire national
adjoint du syndicat indépendant des
commissaires de police
la peine ne dissuade plus à marseille la
situation se radicalise les individus
veulent faire de ces zones de trafic des
zones de non droit nos collègues font
les frais par leur intégrité physique
pour maintenir ces territoires dans le
giron de la république
les fameuses nogo zone on se moquait des
états unis fut un temps aujourd'hui on
en parle de manière sérieuse en france
ces zones de non droit le mot est
vraiment lâchés et décide est ce que ce
mot est approprié ou est-ce qu'on
exagère
honnêtement il se mouiller en partie du
proportionnée pour la 1er simplement de
raison qu'on a déjà eu vent d'une petite
problématique c'est à dire qu'en gros ce
n'est pas l'intégralité de ces quartiers
qui seront posées à la république au
contraire être ces gens là ne demandent
ses citoyens que plus de services
publics plus de sécurité donc plus
effectivement de services régaliens au
quotidien pour sécuriser leurs vies
leurs biens leurs familles ça c'est la
première chose maintenant effectivement
vous avez raison ce terme peut être
utilisé pour une partie de cette
population ultra minoritaire je le
précisais pas dans la stigmatisation qui
refusent de jouer le lait jus de notre
république qui veut absolument escudier
match valait il parlait de cette
population dans l'occurrence qui veut
absolument effectivement son arc aux
trafiquants qui gangrènent ces quartiers
et qu'ils n'ont aucun intérêt à ce qu'on
retrouve un peu de quiétude là dedans
ou un madjid messaoudene ce mot est ce
qui vous fait hérisser le poil ou dans
le fond vous vous dites on commence
c'est un petit peu à se diriger vers ces
zones de non droit aujourd'hui
alors moi je suis rarement d'accord avec
les propos de mathieu gallet
parce qu'il est connu pour avoir des
positions qui n'aide pas a justement
poser les choses sérieusement
moi je parlerais pas de zone de non
droit moi je pense qu'il ya pas un
quartier en france où la police ne peut
pas aller il ya des quartiers
effectivement qui sont très très
difficile on l'a vu notamment à
marseille n'est pas seulement et mais il
ya surtout des zones où le droit le
droit l'accès au droit l'égalité
républicaine ne s'applique pas et je
pense que tant qu'on n'arrivera pas en
fait à à traiter les causes et les
racines du mal qui ronge certains
quartiers on assistera hélas toujours à
ce type d'affrontements entre jeunes et
policiers mais surtout une dégradation
massive des quartiers populaires de
france je vous signale que en fait les
trafics de drogue ça date des années 80
leurs installations on a toujours été
dans le sécuritaire et ça n'a absolument
rien réglé il ya eu effectivement des
plans banlieues qui se sont surtout se
contenter de casser des tours pour
construire d'autres immeubles ou en
profiter pour mettre des familles très
pauvres ailleurs pour les chasser des
centres des centres villes mais du coup
on n'a absolument pas joué sur sociale
et le rapport cornut-gentille de 2010
9.2 bien ces problèmes notamment en
seine saint denis quand il parle de
l'inégalité des publics n clairement
vous l'avez dit tout alors monsieur le
syndicaliste il ya effectivement des
quartiers où les sous en fait qu'ils ne
sont pas perdus par la république mais
abandonnés par la république l'état a
abandonné ses quartiers depuis 30 ou 40
ans tous gouvernements confondus il ya
des quartiers où il ya pas de poste des
quartiers où la poste et ferme sans
prévenir il ya des écoles qui sont dans
un état lamentable marseille en est le
triste exemple il y à des commissariats
vétustes un sur dix je prends voies sur
quatre est vétuste en france vos
collègues notamment hassani jusque
travailler dans des conditions
lamentables souvent les appeler l a pas
de voiture pour venir intervenir donc il
ya plein de choses qui ce qui ce qui se
télescopent mais clairement pour moi le
vrai problème si on veut vraiment
endiguer le problème de la violence dans
les quartiers populaires et notamment
celles qui en qui est engendrée par les
trafics de drogue il faut traiter la
cause sociale dans les quartiers d'un
problème de chômage de misère l'école
n'est pas au rendez vous d'autant qu'on
ne fera pas
tant qu'on ne passera pas aux actus suis
de constat qu'on connaît depuis des
années ça réglera rien il faut les
meilleurs enseignants dans ces écoles là
il faut obliger à abandonner les
enseignants expérimentés à aller dans
ces écoles il faut les policiers les
plus expérimentés il faut les juges les
plus expérimentés et tant que ce ne sera
pas fait tant qu' on ne donnera pas des
gages à ses habitants des quartiers
populaires comme quoi ils sont respectés
alors effectivement il y aura toujours
une défiance face à l'état et plus du 2è
ce que l'état a de l'autorité je dirai
ce que l'état de la crédibilité dans des
quartiers et ma réponse est non
aujourd'hui la défiance est totale ces
quartiers s'abstiennent massivement et
les élus profitent de cette abstention
pour les arbres donner encore plus donc
je pense réellement au delà du fait que
sur la question du trafic de drogue il
faudra se poser avant d'abandonner la
question de la dépénalisation
dépénalisation pardon et de la
légalisation parce que rist claire
mialhe et fabienne pardonnez moi mais on
va y venir parce que je voudrais
rebondir sur ce thème du trafic de
drogue puisque gérald darmanin lui
justement évoque ces trafics de drogue
en balayant cette notion de zone de
non-droit écouter
aucune zone de non droit sur le
territoire de la république à marseille
comme ailleurs à ma demande une
importante opération antidrogue a été
menée aujourd'hui cité des flamants
d'autres opérations suivront bilan
quatre interpellations et saisie de
drogue et d'argent liquide et décide
justement ces trafics de drogue certains
de vos collègues disent c'est justement
pour ça qu'il y à des affrontements
parce qu'on les dérange
dans leur façon de tourner en rond ces
trafics de drogue est ce que il est là
le problème aujourd'hui en tout cas la
cause d'une partie de ces affrontements
effectivement ils vont chaque territoire
a ses spécificités que ce soit au niveau
local régional hcnc nice et à marseille
la position dure avec les géographique
et par là même l'historique de la
voyoucratie non plus la dénégation plus
maintenant les lois la rue de la
république sont les mêmes pour tous
partout et effectivement mais nous
devons prendre en compte des
spécificités de chaque territoire et
c'est vrai que effectivement pour
revenir sur ce que vous me disiez il est
indéniable qu on en passe d certain
nombre d'individus qui va absolument
appliquer ces règles parce qu'en fait
c'est une manne financière fin dantesque
on parle de letra du super fier en
général c'est entre 30 minutes et 80000
euros par jour de chiffre d'affaires
alors ça dépend je l'entends ils devront
aussi plus dans la hausse est moins mais
c'est une réalité et le problème c'est
que on a toute une jeunesse aujourd'hui
effectivement qui se retrouvent à aller
par facilité par commodité peut-être
aussi par un fatalisme étatique je sais
pas moi j'suis pas de politique mais par
contre ce qui est certain c'est que la
route par cette jeunesse qui se dirige
vers sète c'est cette politique là et
est malheureusement ce n'est pas une
réponse dont je pense qu aujourd hui la
réponse est multifactoriel effectivement
en aval elle est sécuritaire c'est
indéniable c'est le droit régalien pour
les citoyens de ces quartiers qui
méritent la même sécurité que
effectivement les quartiers les
habitants du quartier plus aisé puck au
dessus du coup suis trop bien jeune mais
aussi c'est une réponse en amont parce
qu'effectivement sur le bâti sur
l'habitat urbain sur un peu plus de
mixité sociale je me rappelle
effectivement une habitante d'un
quartier de la paillade de montpellier
pour pas parler que de marseille que de
ceni a effectivement été apostrophé le
président républicain ils demandent en
plus de mixité sociale enfin nous on le
voit chaque année donc le problème c'est
que il ya un véritable phénomène dans le
bâti dans l'urbain les bailleurs sociaux
ont leur part de responsabilité
aujourd'hui il ya aussi à l'abandon de
certaines travailleurs sociaux pour pas
une raison des lois sécuritaires ils
peuvent pas travailler en sécurité non
plus je suis prêt à l'entendre mais
c'est vrai que là répond céline
multifactorielle et c'est vrai que nous
ne sont pas l'alpha et l'oméga de toutes
les réponses de démo de ces qu'arsenal
c'est une réalité madjid messaoudene ont
parlé des tarterets tout à l'heure là
effectivement marseille un dealer arrêté
force est d'être relâchés un par ses
copains venus en renfort quand même ça
dit quoi cette affaire c'est qu'on ne
touche pas aujourd'hui clairement au
trafic de drogue qui est assez puissant
dans beaucoup de cités où c'est une
analyse qui à côté pour vous non mais
quel trafic de drogue soit une manne
financière pour certains dans les
quartiers c'est pas un c'est pas un
secret et d'ailleurs ce qui viennent je
fournissais dans ses carnets la bouille
non on parle de surpuissance de deux de
ces trafiquants drame olivier messiaen
l'opéra après encore une fois en
fonction des quartiers des
problématiques qui sont qui sont qui
sont différentes mais à la base le
trafic de drogue pour certaines
personnes représentent une manne
financière importante
après il fait surtout vivre des têtes du
réseau qui souvent ne vivent pas
forcément sur le quartier vont investir
ailleurs et cet argent ne réveille pas
sur les sur les quartiers en question et
les premières personnes qui souffrent de
deux de ses 2 et trafic de drogue et des
conséquences quotidiennes ce sont les
habitants des habitants qui sont
abandonnés par les élus des habitants
qui sont abandonnés par les bailleurs
les habitants qui sont abandonnés par
l'état parce que je le rappelle encore
une fois les services publics sont
défaillants quand elles ne sont pas
inexistants donc tant qu'on ne traitera
pas cette question là clairement du
social sur le bâti si vous laissez
ciriam qui disaient qu'ils étaient là
toujours la même merde derrière la
couche de peinture c'est la réalité
c'est que si vous ne traitez pas les
gens de manière sociale si vous n'aidez
pas des gens à s'élever socialement et
si on se sert du duduk comment dire du
prétexte de la mixité sociale pour
mettre des personnes un peu plus aisée
pour que les autres sont en deuil on n'y
arrivera pas non plus ces personnes ont
le droit d'être où elles sont et de
vivre dignement elles payent des loyers
elles paient des impôts elles ont droit
aux mêmes services publics qu'ailleurs
et force est de constater qu'aujourd'hui
dans certains quartiers alors moi je
connais mieux la seine-saint-denis parce
que j'en ai été élu et j'y vis toujours
et notamment dans un quartier populaire
clairement nous ne sommes pas traités à
la même enseigne c'est flagrant quel que
soit le service public concerné
éducation nationale justice police et
autres donc tant que l'état ne voudra
pas s'occuper de ces populations acquis
pour l'état sont des populations qui
sont pas intéressantes électoralement
clairement le problème il est là tant
que ces populations ne seront pas
perçues comme des citoyens à part
entière mais toujours comme des citoyens
de seconde zone on n'y arrivera pas et
le trafic de drogue encore une fois on
n'en a pas parlé mais tant qu'il y aura
ce set up prohibition et cette chasse
aux autres aux trafiquants de drogue bah
on fera que déplacer le problème et dès
qu'on
coupera la tête d'un réseau d'un autre
réseau qui qui arrivera et on le sait et
on l'a vu partout et par tout ça a été
tenté de régler de manière sécuritaire
qu'au mexique ou ailleurs on a bien vu
que ça ne règle pas le problème donc je
comprends bien c'est une difficulté au
quotidien y compris pour les forces de
police qui interviennent sur sur ces
questions là notamment quand elles font
face à des manques de moyens criant
quand on perd 400 policiers sous le
gouvernement sarkozy c'est quand même
pas à marseille seulement on est on est
pas là sur des affabulations
clairement le problème dans ces cités
c'est d'abord la misère sociale et la
sécurité sociale et tant qu'on ne
traitera la question des quartiers que
sous l'angle sécuritaire 1 c'est
stigmatisant et 2 ça ne réglera rien
dernière réaction justement dans le
pendant de ce que vous nous dites cette
analyse un proche de la voûte d'ailleurs
celle de jean-louis bordeaux borloo dont
le plan dyer avait été un petit peu
écarté par emmanuel macron au début du
quinquennat on s'en souvient l'ancien
ministre de la ville qui dénonce la
persistance d'une ségrégation urbaine
les côtés
dans les quartiers il a quatre fois
moins de moyens qu'ailleurs rapporté au
nombre d'habitants la république fait
beaucoup moins pour ces zones en
apesanteur que pour les autres vous
connaissez un pays qui peut se permettre
d'avoir cent cinquante mille jeunes en
bas des immeubles qu'ils attendent c'est
absurde ces quartiers sont une chance ou
un drame pour notre pays il faut juste
savoir ce qu'on veut
chanson ou drame pour notre prier pays
il dit si d'accord avec cette analyse ou
pour vous allez un petit peu manichéenne
finalement
elle est surtout politicienne voilà on
est à la politique politicienne je me
garderai de d'agrémenter loin sur de
propos par contre ce qui est certain et
je lui explique la police allait à la
l'image de la population est on
aujourd'hui dans nos rangs des collègues
du sud ces quartiers populaires qui font
des carrières brillantes je le précise
aujourd'hui effectivement et il
travaille aussi dans ces quartiers
populaires moi j'étais je pense à
décoller que j'ai croisés que lorsque je
travaille en seine-saint-denis en
l'occurrence sur cinq points ont
déterminé sur scène me robert la
courneuve qu'artiste elle est vitale ce
fameux deuxième district du 93 donc
c'est vrai effectivement que c'est
compliqué il ya beaucoup de
problématiques si les territoires qui
coince entre un grand nombre de
problématiques économiques sociales
démographiques c'est très compliqué la
réponse est multifactoriel aujourd'hui
nous avons besoin de moyens pour encore
pucelle et si effectivement ces
territoires et apporter la sécurité aux
citoyens qui n'ont pas d'autre
possibilité que de vivre ailleurs
malheureusement ces
jours là sans vraiment pardonnez moi l
disi pour parler vraiment
mon basket on a toujours l'impression
c'est vrai quand on fait ce genre de
débat qui est un discours un petit peu
voilà blanc ou noir le tout sécuritaire
c'est pas bon est-ce qu est-ce que c'est
aussi simple que ça vous en tant que
policier question de vous demander à vos
élus justement
ce qu'on demande aujourd'hui en
l'occurrence et des moyens parce qu on
peut dire ce qu'on veut mais il ya eu
des pertes effectif conséquent et je
pèse mes mots sur leurs dans son bar
star c est par exemple petit monde
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas remplacer
l'humain aujourd'hui il faut du de
l'humain il faut de lui-même pour
effectivement éviter que ces jeunes
tombent dans la délinquance ils sont
actuellement sur la délinquance de voie
publique pour certains ils vont rentrer
dans les narcotrafiquants puisque la
manne financière hyper intéressante on a
aujourd'hui la mondialisation qui a
accéléré ce processus parce
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement là on a
interpellé des trafiquants n'était pas
le cas il ya 10 ou 20 ans aduba
effectivement une des filières au
maghreb et c'est trés constitué donc
aujourd'hui effectivement sont souvent
des moyens de pouvoir investir ces
quartiers pour pouvoir apporter un peu
de quiétude et qu'on est nous effectuons
des effectifs en plus je prends le cas
de marseille par exemple où on a perdu
beaucoup de deux de fonctionnaires comme
les dix est effectivement donc le
militant en question je ne voulais pas
le juge koné pardon mais en l'occurrence
effectivement c'est certain aujourd'hui
on a en fait réussi à obtenir des moyens
on veut aussi la vidéo protection du
triangle très concret aujourd'hui david
auprès des gens ça permettrait
effectivement de pouvoir aider et faire
baisser de façon significative la
délinquance de voie publique est on là
certaines agglomérations par dogmatisme
pur et dur aujourd'hui qui refuse alors
que certaines agglomérations comme paris
intra muros par exemple qui sont
eux-mêmes l'obédience politique
aujourd'hui accepter ce que la
vidéoprotection c'est pour protéger les
citoyens au quotidien effectivement on
n'est pas là pour zoomer voilà moi non
moi je vous garantis qu'on oublie c'est
un moyen qui fonctionne jeu des vécus en
seine saint denis je les ai vécus à
saint-ouen je n'ai vécu sur un trafic de
stupéfiants trafic de sucre quand la
main droite à gauche ça permettait
d'intervenir beaucoup plus rapidement et
effectivement aujourd'hui si un des
moyens possibles et probables et c'est
tout ça que présent la république at il
annoncé des départs multifactorielles
vous n'êtes pas d'accord c'est un gros
mot des caméras de vidéosurveillance ou
vidéoprotection
je m'étais opposé à l'époque j'avais
voté contre l'installation parce que
clairement c'était un moyen de se
défausser sur la municipalité de faire
prendre aux policiers municipaux
démission
régaliennes qui incombait jusque là aux
policiers nationaux aujourd'hui le maire
socialiste à armer les policiers
municipaux municipaux pardon ce à quoi
je me suis toujours opposée moi je pense
que chacun son métier et que un policier
national c'est pas un policier municipal
mais au-delà de ça la vidéoprotection
n'y a qu'à les études qui démontrent
qu'ils démontrent qu'ils peuvent être
efficaces à certains endroits c'est pas
la panacée et donc du coup il faut pas
faire croire aux gens que la vidéo
protège lc de la vidéosurveillance pas
de la vidéoprotection elle surveille
elle protège pas et moi et moi je n'ai
pas en droit d'ailleurs si je peux juste
de terminer en deux secondes certains
endroits d'ailleurs où dès qu'elle est
installée on sait qu'elle tient pas
longtemps parce que justement il ya des
endroits où les gens ne peuvent pas se
permettre de laisser des caméras
tournent et donc je pense que clairement
là on est sûr de la facilité au niveau
de la caméra ça peut aider effectivement
la résolution de certains de certains de
certains délits mais clairement c'est
pas ça qui va ramener la paix sociale
dans les quartiers populaires on le sait
très bien mais une dernière chose
monsieur de syndicalistes parce que
pendant n'a pas parlé mais je pense que
c'est important et l'intervenant qui est
acteur et qui en a parlé tout à l'heure
je pense qu'il faudra aussi parler
objectivement du comportement de
certains de nos collègues et
qu'effectivement ça ne participe pas ça
ne participe pas d'une lui parler de
cohabitation avec des policiers ça ne
participe à 2,2 de la confiance entre
notamment des jeunes et et la police
parce que à un moment donné certains
agissements qui sont ultra condamnable
de certains de vos collègues et qu'ils
sont rarement condamnés de la part des
syndicats de police ça non plus ça ne
passe pas on ne casse pas une maman
enfin c'est juste impossible on peut pas
gaz et maman qui vient pour
c'est un exemple est ce que je veux dire
c'est que la question de ce que nous on
appelle les violences policières il
faudra aussi les traiter le comportement
de certains policiers qui ne respectent
pas le code de déontologie il faudra
aussi qu'on abords de ça parce que tant
que tant qu'on aura l'impression qu'il
ya une impunité de certains corps
constitués on ne pourra pas demander l'
exemplarité aux autres dire que s'il n'y
a pas de d'exemplarité de la part de
l'uniforme on peut pas demander aux gens
d'être exemplaires et de la réponse est
le mot de la fin s'il vous plaît alors
pour synthétiser les choses bêtement sur
la sphère des tarterets je ne peux me
permettre de me c'est là dedans la
suisse en train de passer en tout cas ce
qui est certain c'est qu'on est
aujourd'hui deux commissaires qui sont
venus effectivement se présenter et
expliquer la version des faits à la
famille on a des collègues qui sont
intervenus c'est compliqué
l'intervention dans des quartiers
difficiles où tout de suite
effectivement la température pour monter
moi je me garderai bien de tout de tout
jugement ce qui est certain que la
justice doit passer jusqu'à preuve du
contraire mais collet qu'il soit
innocent voilà maintenant ça c'est la
première chose effectivement il ya une
enquête on verra ce qu'il en ressortira
pour l'instant il soit innocent ça c'est
la première chose est de toute façon
plus générale plus globale aujourd'hui à
sa cinquante mille policiers en france
je peux vous dire que rapporte
effectivement au nombre de fonctions de
police présent sur la voie publique il
ya très très peu d'incidents et c'est
pas un petit matin les policiers ont à
mansourah mais ça s'est passé pas
l'objet c'est pour ça que je me suis
regardée mais là on est la voie la mémé
jeu mais je pense que ça doit plus fin
aujourd'hui clairement de la part des
syndicats et jeu et j'ai l'impression de
tous sauf de certains syndicats ultra
minoritaire chez vous c'est une question
qui est taboue et et je pense que tant
que cette question restera ta bonté
qu'il n'y aura pas de 2,2 de lucidité
sur certains cas qui sont inacceptables
entend récemment on
n'arrivera pas à
dire à faire que c'est une formulation
effectivement le l'uniforme de ceux qui
sont là pour protéger des citoyens
on a compris de toute façon son propos
est à tous les deux merci à vous en tout
cas
et on en vient maintenant la situation
sanitaire en outre-mer la nouvelle
calédonie sert confiné depuis ce mardi
midi pour une durée de quinze jours une
décision qui fait suite à la découverte
de 3,4 kobe 19 plus de précision avec
nicolas petit
déjà confiné au début de l'épidémie en
mars 2000 vingt et un ans plus tard en
mars dernier la nouvelle calédonie va
vivre son troisième confinement la
nouvelle est tombée ce lundi après que
les autorités ont annoncé que trois
habitants de l'île géographiquement
éloignés ont été testés positifs au co
vide
ces personnes n'ont aucun lien les unes
avec les autres et n'ont pas voyagé
récemment
cela signifie que le virus a commencé à
circuler en nouvelle calédonie et qu'à
cette heure plusieurs dizaines de
calédonienne et de calédoniens sont
probablement contaminés en plus du port
du masque qui devient obligatoire en
extérieur ce confinement prévue pour 15
jours au moins sa compagne de la
fermeture des crèches établissements
scolaires universités et d'une
interdiction de déplacement les liaisons
aériennes sont suspendus et seuls les
trajets domicile travail pour
consultations médicales achats de
première nécessité et activité physique
dans un rayon d'un kilomètre sont
autorisés une somme de mesures fortes et
justifiée selon le haut commissaire de
la république
ces mesures strictes sont le résultat
d'une décision concertée avec les
autorités calédoniennes éclairé par
l'avis du comité d'experts qui conseille
le gouvernement depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire l'objectif immédiat est
bien de casser les chaînes de
contamination la contagiosité du variant
delta qui a frappé très sévèrement nos
cousins polynésiens et les antilles
françaises nous y oblige alors que l'île
est confrontée à un manque de personnel
médical
les autorités ont fait appel à la
solidarité nationale et annonce que des
renforts seraient demandés si nécessaire
pour l'heure seulement 30 % de la
population a été vaccinée en nouvelle
calédonie
c'est avec nous dans quelques instants j
- avant l'ouverture du procès des
attentats
qualifiée d' historique il devrait durer
neuf mois et se tiendra devant la cour
d'assises de paris rénové pour
l'occasion 300 avocats des parties
civiles défileront à la barre alors que
l'unique survivant du commando salle
abdeslam resté muet pendant
l'instruction sera très attendu à la
barre
[Musique]
vous avez assisté à cette fabrication
d'une machine terrorisme est-ce que vous
êtes surpris de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui pas du tout c'était attendu
de toute façon on savait que les
talibans étaient en train de revenir sur
le terrain depuis déjà des années ce qui
a été balayé ce ne sont pas les talibans
c'est al qaïda qui a été balayé en 2001
et al qaïda est taliban ce ne sont pas
deux concepts superposables comment va
vivre le peuple afghan dans les semaines
qui viennent on va assister à un
raz-de-marée humanitaire absolument sans
précédent y va y avoir des que non pas
seulement pour quitter le pays mais
aussi pour simplement avoir du pain est
donc là il est bien évident la
communauté internationale doit se
mobiliser
c'est notre
devoir moral que de venir en aide à ce
peuple qui a souffert tant par le passé
[Musique]
à
combien s'élève la facture du quoi qu'il
en coûte comment on va se mettre en
place le sur mesure c'est pas une fois
qu'on a dépensé des milliards des
centaines de milliards à arroser tout le
monde et à faire tenir des gens qui
n'auraient jamais dû tenir que
maintenant on va pouvoir se vanter de
faire un peu de sur mesure toute la
question c'est ne pas refaire
aujourd'hui l'erreur de 2011 qui avait
été d'enlever les mesures de soutien à
l'économie après la crise de 2008
beaucoup trop tôt ce qui avait cassé la
dynamique économique de la reprise la
déclaration de bruno le maire il sait
très bien que le jo il arrête c'est fini
vous aurez des sociétés qui feront
failli à ce qu'on leur demandera de
rembourser quelque chose qu'elles ne
peuvent pas rembourser elle en était
bien incapable déjà avant de s'endetter
et aujourd'hui elles ne pourront pas
c'est les chaises musicales si vous
voulez y aura pas cette chaise quand
tout le monde
[Musique]
louis saillant est un ex commandos
marine il nous emmène dans les coulisses
de la guerre contre le djihadisme au
sahel l'ennemi l'abord est parfaitement
légitime qu'on parle de jay liste on
parle de gens qui recrutent des enfants
on parle de gens qui sont d'une barbarie
extrême c'est vrai que c'est un terreau
qui peut favoriser
l'extension du terrorisme ne faut pas
imaginer qu'il suffit simplement d'avoir
un pays pauvre pour que l'islam c'est un
bien acquis sont embrigadés ils ont été
séduits ils ont été manipulés et
d'autres qui agissent de manière
parfaitement consciente et lucide je
respecterai toujours mon adversaire même
si je méprise totalement son idéologie
comme c'est le cas pour sega liste
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
coups politiques n'a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient des
lignes aujourd'hui une gauche
extrêmement utiles à la société
[Musique]
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission est la
justice et le droit et le droit comme
dernier armes pour tenter d'expliquer
l'inexplicable c'est un procès
historique est titanesque qui débute
demain à paris celui des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 ou 130 personnes ont perdu
la vie 20 d'accuser 330 avocat et
quelques 1800 parties civiles c'est la
plus grande audience criminelle jamais
organisé en france mais qui est aussi
redoutés par de nombreux survivants et
par les familles des victimes
[Musique]
avant de parler du procès hors norme les
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 petit
détour politique avec cette sortie janka
sexe pour qui l'heure n'est pas au bilan
alors quand ont-ils par là on en parle
tout de suite avec alexis poulain dans
son édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis poulain merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france l'heure
n'est pas au bilan a paraît-il un nous
dit jean castex mais alors quand et sur
quelle base emmanuel macron peut-il
faire campagne alors oui c'est ce
formidable avec la république en marche
et que l'heure n'est jamais vraiment au
bilan toucher toujours à la
communication alors si c'est pas le
bilan maintenant il faut attendre que le
maquereau et décidé de faire son bilan
pour le moment il a décidé de faire son
auto promo on l'a vu trois jours à
marseille d'une auto promo incroyable où
il sortait le carnet de chèques des
français pour dire qu'il était le
sauveur de la ville là en ce moment
c'est à peu près paraissait des jeunes
avec le maquereau qui s'y colle qui
collent des affiches voilà macro
président des jeunes or les sondages
disent à peu près tout l'inversé on a vu
depuis la crise sanitaire les jeunes
faire la queue auprès des banques
alimentaires bien sûr la réduction des
apl l'entrée dans la précarité un jeune
sur cinq qui a abandonné ses études en
fin de bilan est catastrophique donc il
faut faire de la communication c'est un
peu la réalité alternative à la trump
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où on
va dire des choses on va y croire et
peut-être même que les électeurs les
français vont y croire alors allons-y
pourquoi faire un bilan quand on peut
faire de la com alors pourtant à alexis
on voit une activité bouillonnante 1 à
la république en marche en ce début
septembre qu'est ce que ça signifie
alors ben encore une fois occupé
l'agenda médiatique être là tout le
temps parce qu'en fait la république en
marche ne tient que par emmanuel macron
donc une fois c'est le champion qui est
là pendant trois jours à marseille et
après hop retour au parti aujourd'hui
ils étaient tous pour la rentrée
parlementaire arrangé pour parler se
mettre tous au diapason ses députés de
la république en marche avec que
stanislas guérini qui disait quand même
il y un bilan attention le bilan du
quinquennat c'est plus d'impôts pour les
gaffes à plus de congés pour les papas
voilà c'est à peu près les deux seuls
plus alors l'idée c'est 50 plus avec ces
slogans à pour dire que macron c'est un
peu monsieur plus celui qui a fait le
plus pour la france alors il a aussi bas
faut pas oublier il ya eu des violences
lors des manifestations des gilet jaune
il ya eu aussi la casse des droits
sociaux il veut revenir encore sur la
réforme des retraites pour dire que
c'est un président réformateur parce que
finalement de réforme il y en a eu très
peu donc on voit bien qu'il est un peu
coincé par le temps 100 jours pour agir
donc c'est ce qu'ils veulent faire il ya
ensuite
l'université d'été si on peut dire
puisque ce sera début octobre de la
république en marche à avignon arrivé
après les autres là encore pour occuper
l'espace médiatique et puis on voit les
équipes 1 qui s'installe avec un
débauché de chez orange qui va prendre
en charge la campagne du candidat macron
quand il sera déclarée et le siège bien
sûr le nouveau siège parisien de la
république en marche puisque c'est un
parti ridja ils ont beaucoup de début et
donc aider le député parce qu'en réalité
et très peu d'élus locaux mais ça leur
permet d'avoir un trésor de guerre pour
préparer cette campagne en tout cas
l'opération comme à angers a été plutôt
voilà assombri si je peux me permettre
de me permettre par la mort de jean-paul
belmondo dont on a davantage parlé
certainement alors il n'y a pas que la
raim où on assiste à une communication
politique intense en ce début de rentrée
encore plus de deux candidats et deux
candidates oui alors c'est la rentrée
politique évidemment mais alors comme on
en a les présidentielles c'est un peu
tout et n'importe quoi ça foisonne
arnaud montebourg à clamecy qui arrive
après cette parenthèse d'entrepreneuriat
où pourtant il disait à peu près chaque
année qu'il avait fermé la parenthèse
politique que plus jamais il n'y
reviendra bon ben c'est un peu comme
roselyne bachelot dès qu'on leur propose
un truc ou dès que c'est une année
présidentielle on y va alors pour un an
montebourg a aucun candidat n'a de
programmes et pourtant il repique à peu
près toutes les idées de l'avenir en
commun la plate forme programmatique de
la france assouvissent de jean-luc
mélenchon il essaye on a aussi anne
hidalgo à gauche qui fort de son bilan
la mairie de paris bilan contesté 1 elle
veut aussi se lancer dimanche prochain
lors d'un jt pour annoncer sa
candidature elle prépare ses équipes à
la mairie de paris et puis il ya la
primaire des écolos alors là ça discute
et l'idée c'est de faire oublier un peu
la primaire parce qu'il faudrait qu'un
candidat émerge mais c'est compliqué
entre sandrine rousseau eric piolle
yannick jadot delphine batho et tous ces
mouvances de l'écologie et puis à droite
alors là c'est
une énorme question ils étaient réunis
au parc floral ce week-end et la
question c'est qui ce qu on fait des
primaires sous quelle forme comment on
fait et alors qu'est ce qu'on fait avec
xavier bertrand qu'est ce qu'on fait
avec valérie pécresse et puis eric
ciotti qui avec sa sortie disant qu'ils
seraient prêts à voter pour l'exil moore
alors même qu'ils exhibent où on n'est
pas candidat sème le trouble et bien sûr
eric zemmour lui se lance par contre
dans une campagne d'auto promo à partir
de la mi septembre pour vendre son livre
sous forme de programme donc il y aura
peut-être d'autres surprises dans cette
course à la présidentielle ça ne fait
que commencer et on le fait on
continuera avec vous évidemment alexis
poulain merci à vous
le procès des attentats du 13 novembre
2015 s'ouvrira donc demain devant la
cour d'assises spéciale de paris une
audience hors normes dans une salle
construite pour l'événement et qui
devrait durer près de neuf mois outre
les protagonistes directs ou indirects
de nombreuses victimes seront présentes
pour témoigner et si elles attendent des
condamnations exemplaires elles ont pour
certaines déjà reçu des compensations
financières yves ollivier et farah mais
qu'ils
soient les victimes de terrorisme sont
elles désigner le droit français
distingue la victime directe celle qui a
personnellement subi un dommage en lien
direct avec l'acte est la victime
indirecte
autrement dit un proche ou un ayant
droit dans les deux cas l'obtention
d'une indemnité repose notamment sur
l'expertisé d'un médecin indépendant
ce dernier va de manière individualisée
procéder à une évaluation de l'état de
santé physique et psychologique de la
victime puis il va transmettre ce
rapport à un organisme chargé de
déterminer un montant à hauteur du
préjudice la victime sera indemnisée via
le fonds de garantie des victimes des
actes de terrorisme et d'autres
infractions
le fjt créé en 1986 après une vague
d'attentats ce fonds est financé par une
contribution solidaire prélevée sur
chaque contrat d'assurance de biens
signé en france combien de victimes ont
été indemnisées
d'abord il faut préciser qu aucune
distinction n'est faite entre un
français ou un étranger lorsque les
attentats ont été commis en france les
français victimes de terrorisme à
l'étranger peuvent aussi demander à être
indemnisés depuis 2015 le fjt y a pris
en charge plus de 6300 personnes dont
2600 une pour les seules attaques de
masse à paris et à saint denis en
novembre 2015 parmi elles
2334 se sont vu proposer une
indemnisation définitive
pour plus de 1700 de victimes la
procédure est terminée au total le fonds
de garantie a versé plus de 141 millions
d'euros pour ses attentats peut-on
refuser l'indemnité proposée par le fjt
oui et c'est déjà le cas de 705 victimes
des attentats du 13 novembre 2015
certaines ont par la suite saisi un
médiateur indépendant pour tout ce qui
ne concerne pas le montant de l'offre
d'indemnisation
pour les autres c'est à la juridiction
d'indemnisation des victimes d'actes de
terrorisme
là j'y vas tu de trancher objectif pour
ces neuf magistrats apprécier au cas par
cas la qualité de victime des demandeurs
au début de l'été cette dernière compte
est de 103 dossiers à traiter dont une
majorité liés aux attaques des 13
novembre 2015 et 2 juillet 2016 à nice
créée en 2019 elle a rendu 64 verdict
est octroyé plus de 9 millions d'euros
aux victimes de terrorisme
il faut en parler nous sommes en direct
avec jean pierre albertini père de
stéphane assassiné au bataclan 2015
hauteur de mourir au bataclan aux
éditions mareuil en octobre 2020 bonsoir
jean pierre albertini merci beaucoup
d'être
avec nous on imagine voilà que le moment
est solennel compliqué à la veille de ce
procès dans quel état d'esprit êtes vous
ce procès a réuni dix ans après le crime
donc on a eu le temps de s'habituer à
notre
situation de familles de victimes et
ce au c'est donc est un procès pénal est
donc ce que l'on attend c'est que les
peines qui seront infligées seront à la
hauteur du crime et est ce qu'on espère
surtout c'est que dans celle mois seront
prononcées surtout qu'elles seront
effectives effectué et nora concis parce
que si l'on reprend tous les assassins
du bataclan ils étaient tous connus de
la police fichés
le premier était sous contrôle
judiciaire qui ne respectaient pas donc
ce que je peux espérer au minimum c'est
que ce procès pénal
appliquent des sanctions qui seront
effectivement réalisé
aujourd'hui ces condamnations elles
concernent on imagine évidemment ça
d'abdeslam qui est le seul rescapé aussi
quelques complices mais vous le disiez
il ya eu certains dysfonctionnements
peut-être parce qu'ils étaient connus
ces assassins de l'êta aujourd'hui ce
sont des condamnations mais aussi une
reconnaissance de certaines familles
c'est bien cela
oui je crois que les études qui ont été
faites et notamment l' enquête
parlementaire qui a été réalisé en 2016
ont montré effectivement des failles
dans le renseignement
des failles aussi dans le la ligne
politique que la ligne judiciaire et
j'espère que ce procès permettra au
moins de démonter et de démontrer tout
ce qui a dysfonctionné et surtout pour
empêcher que les chose de semblable se
reproduise
aujourd'hui on le disait un donc le seul
rescapé du commando du 13 novembre ces
salles abdeslam il est resté
désespérément muet pendant toute
l'instruction aujourd'hui vous attendez
quelque chose de cet homme d des
explications
non honnêtement il est resté une mini
jupe en sisal et je ne pense pas qu'il
va
soudain se déclarer c'est en fait c'est
un lâche je pense qu'il n'a pas activé
sa son gilet de songer des explosifs
alors on dit qu'il y avait un
dysfonctionnement vaut peut-être mais en
fait c'est un marché puis tous ces
conflits se sont aussi des gens qui ont
travaillé pendant une année pour des
assassinats bien prémédité donc ce sont
tous des coupables à des niveaux bien
sûr différent et l'instruction je pense
as-tu le démontrer et donc je pense que
lors de ce procès du japon dans des
choses intéressantes pendant les huit
mois puisque dans ces huit mois il ya
seulement un mois qui est dévolue aux
témoignages des victimes donc laisser
les autres mois sont dévolues à
l'explication de tout ce qui a été
découvert à travers l'instruction
aujourd'hui justement vous proches de
victimes mais également les les
survivants ce sont ces réponses que vous
attendez
ces explications qui seront évoqués
pendant ces sept longs mois de savoir ce
qui s'est passé
oui je pense pour de la bulle en jeu
classique des eaux cge judiciaire des
procès pénaux je pense qu'effectivement
le deuxième enjeu ces deux connaître le
fonctionnement de ces réseaux leur
financement la manière dont les
assassins se sont promenés à l'intérieur
et à l'extérieur de l'espace schengen
dans tous ces mécaniques qui sont
démontés et qui normalement devrait
empêcher que cela se reproduise et puis
bien sûr je pense qu'on ne pourra pas
éviter de cons d'essayer de comprendre -
quels sont les idéologies sous jacente
qui ont permis à des jeunes qui étaient
quand même
qu'ils vivaient en europe et qui avait
la chance d'être dans des pays
démocratiques en paix à des jeunes qui
ont osé
tué lâchement des jeunes de la même
génération donc je pense qu au dollar
des peines et au delà des explications
je pense qu'il y aura une explicitation
2 de lait biologique a permis cela parce
que pour nous ce sont des assassins mais
de leur côté ce sont presque des héros
vous disiez tout à l'heure pour que ça
ne se reproduise pas aujourd'hui
clairement six ans
après vous estimez qu'il ya eu tout de
même un progrès ce genre d'attentât on
voit en france on peut encore arriver
alors je pense que au minimum il y a eu
une prise de conscience du danger
je pense qu'en 2015 la menace n'était
pas évalué à sa juste mesure et qui a eu
une sous-estimation de la menace
notamment par les élites et des et les
personnes qui dirigeait le pays à
l'époque donc une sous-estimation un
génie sans doute à mais la méthode cauet
ne marche pas dans ce genre de deux
domaines donc je pense effectivement
qu'il ya eu prise conscience et au delà
vers les consciences il y a eu quand
même des améliorations
des procédures et et et des lois
concernant le terrorisme jean pierre
albertini est ce que vous allez vous
même assister à ce procès si oui est ce
que il y à une appréhension à revivre
tous ces moments oui bien sûr évidemment
je vais bien sûr assisté au possible
peut-être pas tous les jours puisque il
a été décidé qu'il y aurait une web
radio qui permettrait de suivre en
permanence
même depuis chez soi les audiences avec
un léger décalage dans le temps
de bierges pas de décalage donc j'irai
pour les audiences qui me paraît très
importante je sais que l'ancien de paix
dans la république ancien ministre
d'intérieur l'ancien premier ministre
vont témoigner
je pense qu'il y aura des jours qui
seront importants et au delà il peut y
avoir des événements au pot des 8 - qui
feront que ce procès pendant une
dimension encore plus importante que ce
pour lui donne aujourd'hui vous pensez à
quels événements
en définition les évènements inattendus
de ne sont pas connues
toutes sortes d'événements des
événements politiques des événements
militaires ou des événements
sécuritaires tout est possible un procès
c'est un tel organe vivant donc tout est
possible et ça dure huit mois a été tuée
en plus une année préélectorale donc
beaucoup d'enjeu seront évalués au
travers de ce procès qui évidemment d'un
procès pour nous un procès d' assassin
mais comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure qui est par vu par d'autres yeux
une vitrine pour certaines idéologies
qui fait merci beaucoup en tout cas jean
pierre albertini un père donc de
stéphane assassiné au bataclan en 2015
merci d'avoir été avec nous d'avoir
accepté notre interview ce soir et bon
courage merci
ea procès qui risque donc de raviver le
disais à l'instant des souvenirs
extrêmement douloureux l'association
paris aide aux victimes a été missionné
pour mettre en place un dispositif de
soutien psychologique pour les parties
civiles qui en auraient besoin
l'audience mais aussi chez eux pour en
parler nous sommes avec hélène romano
psychothérapeute spécialiste dans le
psycho traumatisme bonsoir hélène romano
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on en parlait à l'instant avec un
proche de deux victimes c'est important
véritablement ce procès pour les
victimes
les procès sont souvent très important
parce que les victimes espèrent avoir
des réponses à leurs questions alors il
ya par heure contre deux enjeux qui
peuvent rendre les choses difficiles
c'est le délai dans le temps et on est à
6 ans c'est assez fréquent du fait d
instruction d enquête que les délais
soient le montrent les faits et maman ça
passe au niveau judiciaire et puis
l'autre enjeu aussi c'est que certaines
fois à l'issue d'un procès la hiver
particulièrement long
quand les procès d'assises dure à peu
près une semaine mali un procès
d'assises on a certaines fois un très
grand décalage avec les attentes et
blessés psychiques des familles et des
personnes impliquées et contient un
décalage qui est trop violent par
exemple et peines légères un
acquittement des sanctions qui
apparaissent bien faible par rapport à
la gravité des faits c'est pour les
victimes extrêmement violent donc c'est
un temps très important bien au risque
au niveau psychique justement 130 morts
une des plus grandes attaques que la
france ait connu sans compter évidemment
les victimes collatérales on peut se
demander est-ce que justice peut-elle
être rendus ou forcé ment nécessairement
il y aura eu une déception de la
frustration à l'issue de ce procès tout
dépend ce qu'on met derrière un mot
justice ces dernières un mot justice on
met la loi qui passons mais
l'application de la loi
on met donner du sens au fait tout
dépend de ce que chacun va mais derrière
le terme justice je voudrais simplement
rappeler que derrière toutes ces
personnes des cp on a des proches où on
a évalué au niveau des cellules de gens
seuls projets qu'ils soient intervenus
dit favre un proche parent personnes
décédées vous imaginez le nom de
personnes endeuillées faut pas les
oublier on a un certain nombre d'enfants
orphelins aussi des victimes
collatérales de ces attentats qui très
souvent pas forcément la parole à moi
comparativement aux huit mois deux
restent d'audience il faut bien
évidemment si on se croise m et les
personnes blessées psychiquement les
victimes directes les victimes
indirectes sont aussi à prendre en
considération leur parole est à prendre
en considération
puis d'avoir un décalage entre les
attentes la logique psychique et
psychologique des gens et la logique
judiciaire et là ça fait très peur on
entendait ce monsieur justement nous
dire qu'il attendait lui d'aider
condamnation aussi une reconnaissance
des défaillances de la part notamment du
renseignement c'est très différent
j'imagine en fonction des victimes
certaines attentes des condamnations
peut-être tout simplement des
explications si tant est qu'on puisse en
avoir
il ya autant personnes impliquées dans
un procès de deux victimes que
d'attentes on a des situations
extrêmement différents thèmes au sein
des mêmes familles à des attentes
extrêmement différents il ya des
questions très précises qui seront
posées par crpm supporte la famille
son discours sur la façon dont les
services d'orange d'euros est informé
par mais sur l'organisation des prises
en charge je pense à une
multitude de questions il y aura
inévitablement a forcément les réponses
à toutes les questions probablement que
les personnes qui vont être auditionnés
pour les responsables institutionnels et
6 rebonds d'apporter leur vérité leurs
éléments de compréhension et c'est pas
pour autant que ceux-ci iront en phase
avec les attentes des familles y a des
fois un grand décalage aux personnes qui
se disent en cause en tant que accusé
l'agent votre invité est précédemment il
est fort peu probable qu'ils le
reconnaissent quoi que ce soit qui se
remettent en cause le risque c'est
qu'ils utilisent le procès pour
justement faire la promotion la
rigologie
aujourd'hui justement on en parlait avec
alain vittek précédent à monsieur
albertini s'adapter ça mais et le sommes
vraiment voilà qui incarne aujourd'hui
ces attaques puisque les autres par
définition sont décédés il n'y aura pas
justement aussi de la frustration
puisqu'on sait que cet homme est resté
mutique jusqu'à présent risque qu'il ne
parle pas est ce que cela ne va pas
rajouter
justement la déception et au malheur de
ses proches de victimes et de ses
victimes
alors pour avoir accompagné en tant que
thérapeute incertain de victimes du
bataclan avec d'autres collègues on a
quand même essayé d'anticiper ça parce
que on sait pas la procédure qui n'a
rien dit
on n'est pas dans des situations les
personnes disent quelque chose avec
audion se rétracte protease autres là on
est face à quelqu'un qui est vraiment
entré dans son silence qui est aussi sa
force il s'est aussi de façon continue
de faire souffrir les personnes
endeuillées les personnes ont survécu
donc il est fort probable qu'ils ne
parlent qu'ils étaient moins tu s'excuse
en fait les victimes ont besoin de
comprendre pas vraiment comprendre que
la fais ça s'arrête là qu'on prend c'est
d'avoir des excuses là on a tout à fait
joujou avec ce type de personnalité qui
procédera pas à ça les proches sont
préparés en tout cas pour la majorité
des thérapies de kaffrine directive
bataclan à préparer au fait qu'il ne
fallait rien attendre de lui par contre
attendre des responsables politiques
institutionnelles de comprend comment ça
c'est ainsi qu'est ce qui a eu des
failles si jamais un autre drame
survient qui est pâle et autant de
personnes décédées là il ya beaucoup
d'attentes il faudra vraiment le poids
des attentes à mon avis est davantage
portée aujourd'hui sur les responsables
institutionnels
que sur les mises en cause directe qui
seront
poursuivis parquet ils sont pensés pas
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure juste
titre il ya énormément de victimes est
évidemment pas seulement c 130 voilà
personnes décédées des orphelins des
endeuillés aujourd'hui quel est l'état
d'esprit qui prédomine si tenté qu'il y
en ait un état d'esprit qui prédomine
parce que souvent au lendemain des
attentats on avait droit à des discours
finalement où il n'y avait pas de haine
plutôt
voilà de la tristesse mais pas vraiment
de haine aujourd'hui clairement comment
vont ses victimes est ce qu'elles sont
dans la résilience
il n'y a pas d'études quantitatives qui
ont qui a été fait sur leur santé
psychique de ses victimes donc ça sera
plus sur un retour par rapport à
outrance vivement qu'on a entre
collègues par rapport aux
4 applique personne qui est blessé et
psychiquement qu'elle était agressée
elle a rarement de la colère le niveau
de vengeance c'est assez rare chez les
personnes
déjà ou non ça se passait outre au
pavillon ti pour avoir les narines des
tons couleur et puis après souvent elles
sont super g par beaucoup payent
beaucoup de chagrin dans d'autres cadres
des maltraitances il ya la honte la
culpabilité la ya beaucoup de peine
beaucoup de chagrin vraie souffrance une
colère contre les institutionnels contre
les terroristes pour certains et moi je
ne paie pas en tout cas de retour de
notion de vengeance comme certains
enfants n'a plus longtemps mais il ya un
besoin de compréhension la colère des
traces un vide des explications par
rapport à ce qu'il s'est passé et se
vide là est un super parce que ça
et j'ai une maman veillée qui déjoue pas
que mon mari ce rapport pour rien je
vais pouvoir dire à mes enfants qu'est
ce qui fait que votre papa est mort pour
quelle raison il est mort ce soit à
cause des théologies
divers et variés que ce soit
services de secours j'ai besoin de leur
donner des réponses je peux pas moi tout
en tant que maman portait les seules
vraies c'est la responsabilité donc la
plupart des personnes endeuillées
directement son compte dans cette
dynamique là et les personnes blessées
survivants du bataclan soro souvent pour
certaines en grande difficulté psychique
avec cette culpabilité d'avoir survécu
et d'avoir des proches qui lundi ce
n'était même pas mort arrive est abattu
faute revient à la vie c'est très
compliqué pour les survivants direct
pour les proches et douloureux aussi
pour amélie sur lui en direct ils sont
là on va parler des morts aussi parlé
des vivants qui sont des fois dans un
entre deux ils sont mort me survivre ils
sont physiquement ils survivent en
physique en il ya quelque chose en eux
qui est mort ce jour-là faut pas le
banaliser
c'est important de le reconnaître parce
que si une souffrance psychique avilit
très compliqué
merci beaucoup hélène romano je rappelle
que vous êtes aux psychothérapeutes
spécialiste dans les psycho traumatiques
merci d'avoir été avec nous en direct
sur rt france et c'est la fin de cette
émission merci de l'avoir suivi rendez
vous demain dès 20 heures et prochains
projets sur l'actualité ce sera une
trentaine de minutes
[Musique]
si paris cette saison avec lionel messi
remporte la ligue des champions